hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control ac.l
2-3.1.11 terminate automatically of
course a user session after a defined
condition
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got good news for you
you've found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's go so in
cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.11 terminate automatically a
user session after a defined condition
we are looking into further safeguarding
our systems from some kind of hijack
scenario a few examples here you get up
to use the bathroom right so everybody's
got to go nature calls once in a while
uh and a malevolent evil user walks by
your computer and sits down and begins
to use it and access cui oh
uh another example is VPN connections
VPN connections should terminate after a
certain number of minutes of inactivity
for essentially the same reason we don't
want an unauthorized connection to sort
of hang out there forever because
eventually a bad guy or unknown remote
attacker could gain access to that
session uh to not just your own local
system but also the remote system if the
VPN were to be left on and believe it or
not that is actually pretty common right
so an attacker gets control your
computer they hang out in silence you go
trigger your VPN into your company or
your data center and then all of a
sudden you know you walk away shut down
the computer whatever you think it's
gone but then the remote attacker kind
of comes into in the morning they wake
the computer back up or they're on the
computer and the VPN connection is still
there which means they can still get
into the main Network pretty pretty
frightening especially if they use the
key logger or a packet sniffer I won't
go there but that's kind of how it's
done all right so what are the assessors
looking for and how do we solve for all
this uh they're looking for two points
on this one number one they want to
determine if conditions requiring a user
session to terminate are defined now the
easy answer here is it's defined via
group policy and it's enforced that's
one way to do it but also you might have
to look at your firewall as well because
you've also got VPN policies you've got
all kinds of different potential areas
that this policy could exist and again
you just want to generally make sure
that that it has been defined somewhere
could also be a written policy by the
way but more than likely it's going to
be a policy like Group Policy now second
assessment Point determine if a user
session is automatically terminated
after any of the defined conditions
occur yes after 30 minutes of vital time
or 45 minutes of vital time or five
minutes of idle time it doesn't really
matter but you do have to Define it and
you have to dictate what those
conditions are and what is the condition
so it's idle time that's usually the
most common one now the good news is
that we are here to help with that kind
of thing so if you're a defense
contractor and you're trying to figure
out all of this dfar's nist itar cmmc
compliance stuff and it was just dropped
in your lap like a seagull on a sunny
day well the good news is we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that is what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance
service roll it out until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you